in Fire and Blood and House of the
Dragon young princess rhaenyra is
proclaimed the realm's Delight in the
book we first hear about her at the age
of six when she's described as
precocious Bright Beautiful and bold as
she gets older her Uncle Damon claims
that she's one of the most beautiful
women in the realm she keeps her silver
gold hair and braids prefers expensive
Fabrics like lace and velvet and wears a
lot of jewelry one of House of the
dragon's earliest shots features teenage
rhaenyra riding her Dragon through the
skies above King's Landing the princess
of Dragonstone is an accomplished dragon
rider in the books as well it appears
that production designers are using
costumes particularly colors to convey
the maturity intentions and allegiances
of characters Millie alcock's young
rhaenyra often wears pastels and
uncomplicated hairstyles while adult
rhaenyra played by Emma Darcy is decked
out in Reds and blacks and layers of
jewels with her hair in sophisticated
plates while adult rhaenyra gains weight
after childbirth in the book it looks
like showrunners opted to leave this
change out of House of the Dragon